i go out of my dock at night up north
where i am now
and it's dark and this the expanse of
the heavens is laid out above me
and i look up
well i'm not thinking religious thoughts
i'm confronting infinite
the infinite itself and that moves you
inside and i would say it even moves you
to imitation you know because you know
what it means to have your head in the
stars
right i mean it means to be oriented up
in the highest possible manner and so
we're so compelled to imitate again at
an instinctual level that we can even
imitate the infinite that we see spread
above us in the night sky and that's a
religious calling
and all this talk about whether you
believe in god and it's all
propositionalized it's like
well it misses the point it's that's why
i don't ever answer when people say do
you believe in god i say what do you
mean by believe
and they think well you know what i mean
it's like no you don't know what you
mean you have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize that
you're peppering the question with to
force me into a box to deliver the kind
of answer that your question demands
given the way you phrased it
it's like
no
do you think you've made headway on this
when when you've talked i watched uh
just about a week ago with your your
chat with uh stephen pinker and jonathan
hey two guys who i hold in the highest
like intellectual regard i've had them
on the show i i like them both very much
they come from the more atheist
perspective on this you know we've
talked about this a million times
yeah so they think like right right okay
so that that's it
that's where your argument is that i'm
going to cambridge and oxford to talk
about this like in detail what i just
laid out it's like because i what i want
to do is especially when i go to the uk
in these conversations is i want to lay
a tech i lay out a technical argument
for sacred depth so imagine this
we have a intuition that there's depth
in literature
because we think well that's a shallow
story and that's a deep story and we
think well that was really compelling
and gripping it hit me at a profound
level right versus well that was just
light entertainment light right
we all have those intuitions
so what is this depth
and how far down does it go well it goes
down to the bottom of things
what's at the bottom well what's at the
bottom is by definition religious
and why would i say that well it's
because when things move you at that
level
that's how you experience it it's not
thought
it's way deeper so it's like
you go out i go out of my dock at night
up north where i am now and it's dark
and this the expanse of the heavens is
laid out above me
and i look up
well i'm not thinking religious thoughts
i'm confronting infinite
the infinite itself and that moves you
inside
and i would say it even moves you to
imitation you know because you know what
it means to have your head in the stars
right i mean it means to be oriented up
in the highest possible manner and so
we're so compelled to imitate again at
an instinctual level that we can even
imitate the infinite that we see spread
above us in the night sky and that's a
religious calling
and all this talk about whether you
believe in god and it's all
propositionalized it's like
well it's it misses the point
it's that's why i don't ever answer when
people say do you believe in god i say
what do you mean by believe
and they think well you know what i mean
it's like no you don't know what you
mean you have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize that
you're peppering the question with to
force me into a box to deliver the kind
of answer that your question demands
given the way you phrased it
it's like
no
you say you don't believe in god it's
like well god is ineffable
what do you mean you don't believe in
god well what do you believe in them
nothing
well no everything well no that doesn't
work because then you're chaotic well
what's your highest value diversity
equity
inclusivity
well i don't need a highest value well
yes you do because otherwise nothing
orients you through the landscape of
choices
this isn't optional so to give the devil
is due then yeah when you've when you've
had the conversations with a lot of
these guys you just talked to sam harris
again also you know all of these guys
that went great by the way at the end um
you know people that are not necessarily
believers your your basic argument i'm
doing a little 101 here is that you're a
believer whether you believe it or not
that that you're being well harris yeah
okay let's take harris is a good example
harris does not believe in god
but he believes in the devil
so he's halfway there
and why do i say he believes trump is
the devil yeah yeah but that okay but
that's a mistake he also believes
religion is the devil and that's also a
mistake so what do i mean when i say
that he believes in the devil well all i
did the last time i talked to sam was
asking questions
that was a way but and that's something
i highly recommend as a
as a strategy like just find out from
the person you're talking to what they
think
you know
and don't try to win
try to learn
well so sam is really motivated by the
same thing that motivated me like 30
years ago he looked at the panoply of
human atrocity
it terrified him right right to the core
it's like well anything but this and he
wants something like an objective
standard of values now he thinks it can
be found in science i think that's
technically wrong but it's it's an
argument worth having and we we don't
know how to sort out the relationship
between science and values but the thing
is is that sam certainly believes in
evil
okay well if you believe in evil you
also believe in good because good is the
opposite of evil whatever that is
and well what's god good what's god well
god is what's good
well okay what does that mean is he a
spirit like is he a spirit in the sky
what do you mean by spirit
so here here's a here's something to
think about this is what i think
when i look back at the good men
that i've been fortunate enough to know
in my life
there's a spirit that shines through
each of them
that makes them good that's how i can
tell that each of them is good well the
essence of that good that's no different
than god
it might even be god
now you say well what does that mean
that spirit well it's whatever is common
among good men let's say
was that real well isn't what's common
among things more real than what's
different
and why a spirit well it animates them
like it's an it's an animating force
it's not a disembodied abstraction which
is the problem with like conceptions of
god like einstein's conception it's so
disembodied it has no connection to the
world
and that that causes the death of god
that abstraction
eliader
documented deaths of god in many
cultures across history it's not only
something that happened in the west that
nietzsche announced and it happens when
the idea of god gets so abstracted that
it no longer has any connection with the
world
well and those are the things i'm going
to talk about at cambridge and oxford
it's like and i'm going to talk to
richard dawkins
so that's so cool because i'd like to
ask him some questions and because
dawkins is smart and he's put forward
maybe the most coherent biologically
oriented
argument for clockwork determinism
something like that well jordan i mean i
have to tell you this is what i mean i
know you know this but when we were on
tour i think the thing that you change
me on more than anything else i talk
about in my book there were two things
it was the importance of being a parent
because you would always say
most people to live a fully actualized
life have to go through that experience
there are some exceptions but most
people but the other one was connecting
to belief and and i think what what
changed me
on this was watching you
do these lectures every night saying the
truth saying i'm just saying what i
believe to be true and trying to take my
thoughts to the to the end and then i'll
explore them further the the next night
but then seeing that translate into real
world change for people the literally
thousands of people who had
unbelievable stories about the terrors
that they had been through that had
turned their lives around and i thought
that that is the higher good that that
is god that it's not that it's
we can do the whole definition game and
all that but but that you
especially at the peak of that thing
were expressing something that was so
profoundly true that we all know that
maybe we can't exactly get into the box
that we can just hand to somebody and
say this is it
but that that was enough to move me i
think that's i think that's really the
argument you're trying to make that
you'll you'll bring to cambridge and
oxford and to dawkins and everybody else
yeah well and i would say in your
situation i know you're contemplating
fatherhood and it's probably the right
spirit to inhabit you as a
political
commentator let's say a cultural
commentator that's a good way to
reconstrue it you know to the degree
that you can be because you're getting
old enough now to that's the right role
you know you're not sort of upward
striving hero youth
it's that you're in that transition
and like benevolent father
that's that's a good one man
and there's no short there's no limit to
the number of people you can bring that
to
and there's no limit to how much good
that'll do in your own life and and in
relationship to your own children
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell